all right welcome back hop
brethren and sister in of the hot breath
of verse i am your host
comedian joel byers and this is hot
breath
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros and our guest
today is all about our mission our
mission here at hot breath
is to cultivate the next generation of
great self-made
comics and after 300 interviews today's
guest
is laying out the blueprint for us all
to follow not only in self-producing our
own content
but also owning our own content and
creating our own success instead of
waiting for someone else's approval
a career that started as a 16 year old
performing at a church talent show has
boomed into i'll say it the tyler perry
of the internet and now most recently
his announcement of a new soundstage
he's about to be
the kev on stage of the world so ladies
and gentlemen of the hot breath verse
without further ado
welcome to the show the one and only kev
on stage everyone let's show them some
love here
that was a great interview i mean uh
intro
joe appreciate it i appreciate you for
doing this
seriously and we got a lot of people
already jumping in the chat here
so this will be a q a as well so if you
have any questions
feel free to um post them here and we'll
get to as many as we can
but um first things first i've got to
ask you from this because this is
something we connected on
and several things we connected on i
realized through researching you but
the things you credit for your success
are your faith and family and
what i have found in my experience i
didn't decide to pursue comedy until my
senior year of college after praying
about
am i following this business degree or
my calling and then i met my wife in
college who has been
just my rock and support through this
entire 10-year comedy journey i've been
on
so if you could i just heard you mention
that briefly in an interview i would
love for you to kind of expand on how
your faith and family
you how you credit that for really your
success
well i mean my first
material was from church i'm a black
church kid
through and through i spent 99 percent
of my life
from birth to 30 in church
especially the first 10 12 years of my
life
15 years uh in church especially when i
was really young we used to go
five days a week literally the only day
we
go consistently was monday
but uh or five or six days a week
you know pretty you know religiously no
pun intended
but um so that's my that's what i was
observing that's what i was taking in
that's what i was
first mocking my first bits were
things that i saw you know my first
audience was after church
you know my mom grandma we would sit at
home
and watch star search and eat pie and
they'd be like do the do sister daniel
shout
or how did this person preach and
remember when the person was stumbling
over do that kev
you know so that was my first audience
my first performance stage was
church you know singing in the choir or
playing the drums you know later the
bass and piano or
you know we used to have pyp which is
pentecostal young people's
um i don't know what to use that for uh
university or united
i don't know but we we got to do
sketches and
plays so the church was all of my whole
universe you know and it's my first
audience my first
viral sketch was a church about i mean a
sketch about
uh black church girls and black parents
so
uh my first performance was at a church
talent show
i mean that's literally all all i knew
uh so that's you know the the part of me
that i still connect with to this day
a lot of my you know messages i always
kind of do a message at the end to keep
your distance that comes from the church
being in so many doggone services and
you know my pastor my last pastor in
washington
he literally could preach about anything
he preached about
the red sox breaking the curse
when they they came back and beat the
yankees and then won the world series
that year
and it was legit like oh my god i'm so
inspired this is amazing
so you know that joke where i take
anything and preach on it
also comes from church so i mean it was
everything man yeah
and how important has your wife been
through all this journey
listen i'm gonna tell you right now joe
byers and this is no lie
my wife if i do not have her i i am not
sitting before you here right let me
just count the ways
one when i got fired
she kept working so we had a house
and could pay our mortgage and i was on
unemployment and then she let me do
comedy
and build myself up two
she is the best jo
she's not a great joke tagger right
but she is a great teller of this joke's
not working
this is too long this is why there was a
joke i used to kill with
and right before my first tour that i
produced it could i couldn't get it to
work the way it used to work
and i was talking to her about it
because she'd been married to me she's
watched a lot of stand up
specials show she was like your timing
used to be much faster when you got into
that joke
part of the thing that made it work was
the speed and how you did this and this
boom boom boom lately you've been
slowing it down and it's not building an
intensity like you used to you should
try going
harder and i was like you're right joe
fixed it right away i mean literally
fixed a bit
for me and i closed with it all year one
joke was not working and i'm like hey
what do you think wrong with this she
was just like
this is not that funny i was just you
know it's not that funny
keep your distance comedy i completely
bombed on the thanksgiving special i
mean
i mean joe i ate it
luckily for me it was the one that
wasn't taped alive i was gonna bomb
whether it was live or not
luckily it wasn't live so i'm sitting in
the car like
sure you know you've had those sets
where you're just like should i do this
anymore oh yeah
for sure oh bad i don't know if i should
do this
and she was like no you were super
distracted like this whole week you've
been
you've been getting ready for the app
you've been shooting sketches usually
you know you take the time to make sure
your set is good
and this time you just went up there and
did it also she was like you were
talking to the cameras you weren't
talking to the audience
as a whole also it's cold outside so
you're gonna have to literally warm the
audience up they're not gonna be going
as hard at the very beginning because
it's winter time and we're performing
outside
very differently than we were performing
in july where it's warm the sun's out
like literally the body it's hard to
laugh when you're physically cold
you know what i mean like you want to do
this so she was like if you need to go
back
to back in the day when you sit in the
living room and run your jokes by me
and my sister her younger sister is an
even harsher critic she doesn't think
anything's funny
um if you want to do that you make sure
you do that
because you can't go out there like that
again so those are just two ways she's
like my dog on wartime consecuti
she's my uh rock she keeps me humble she
keeps me inspired
uh i literally would not be here without
her
no no hyperbole no exaggeration
i would be just another and her business
acumen
oh yeah joe yo
so she is my secret sauce she's
she's the she's the 11 herbs and spices
she's the whatever you know that's what
black pastas always do she's the almond
to my joy she's the
nougat in my snickers she's the ham
hocks in my greens
i love her you know so uh she's she's an
imperative part i love i love hearing
that because i credit i mean
maya i just self-produce my own comedy
special
and congratulations thank you thank you
kev yeah and uh i
i called it the trophy husband and
[Laughter]
and what um what my wife and i just
discovered my father-in-law was googling
me
and the second when you go into the
search bar and it pulls down like it
autofills the second search term was
joel buyer's wife
so really she's yeah she's getting into
the zeitgeist over here
but so i knew she's helped me
tremendously and i heard you say the
same about your wife so i just wanted to
like
just share more about that and show that
credit because it's
beyond valuable yeah yeah man i'm glad
you know
yes yeah and people are asking
um about well one asked who joel byers
is so i appreciate you
yo we have over 300 interviews with
comics on this uh
channel so if you love comedy we have
all the 85 south crew on here we have
jeff foxworthy cedric entertainer
just uh subscribe to us and support
because
oh oh i go i go way bizac with the 85
south folks okay joe now you didn't have
to take bizac
you know i really admire that man i was
looking through who you interviewed and
one thing i
really suck at is cold reach out do you
have any tips
for like how you book people because i
don't know i
don't i don't know how to do it it's
it's really come down to
just sometimes it's a instagram dm
sometimes it's a tweet
sometimes i email their website
sometimes i email
their management and things like that
like but you have a blue check so you
could probably just slide in the dm and
anybody would pull up you know
it's good to know yeah yeah i've been
afraid to reach out i've seen them get
booked on other
uh you know podcasts and stuff and i'm
like how they get them but i also never
asked so i'm like how'd you get that
like did you ever ask exactly
what if they say no i'll be embarrassed
that is how we can create a problem
before it even exists of like why isn't
this happening to me and it's like well
did you try
no i did it you know we can start to
look at other comics
and compare why did they get that but i
think it took me like eight years in
this game
to realize like you can only focus on
what you can't control
that's all you can do that's all you can
do joe biden yeah
so what what we're doing here i mean i
kind of just gave you a rundown of the
show
and like the people we've had on and our
mission of like
basically cultivating the next
generation of great comics
like what advice do you have for us i
mean we have a weekly podcast we have a
daily writing club we have a facebook
group
where we do a lot a bunch of different
events and things
we have classes and workshops and our
own private membership group as well but
like from your own
experience in this game like what can we
do as in my opinion
comedy's best kept secret how can we
what can we do to no longer be a secret
here kev help us out give us the sauce
i think um first of all you're doing a
lot of stuff
right now i think the biggest thing
it's kind of like weight loss like i
know
what to do you need to eat right and
work out
the part that's actually the hardest is
to do it consistently for a long
time even when it doesn't look like it's
working
and i think that's really the only
difference between myself and a lot of
other people
i'm relentlessly consistent i'm not
necessary and i mean this and i'm a big
fan of myself
i know i'm not the best stand-up
comedian on earth i know i'm not the
best
content creator on earth i know i'm not
the most
handsome person on earth i know i'm not
the most physically fit
but i am one of the most
consistent content creators
on the face of the earth i'm gonna put
that video up
it may not be perfect it may not be
hilarious but it's gonna be
posted as listen i i pride myself
on when you come to my page you will see
an attempt at being funny
pretty much every day over the last
eight years
i i consider myself more of a uh a
cartoonist like a comic book i mean not
coming book
um the funny pages uh what is that
called
you know the comic strip the comics yeah
uh yeah i used to read the newspaper
when that was a thing and i used to love
calvin hobbs
and some days calvin and hobbes was
hilarious some days it was just okay
but every single day it was there you
know what i'm saying and that's kind of
how i market myself like
you can come in for a laugh and if i got
nothing you'll see another creator's
page but you won't see me just not
putting a
shot up you know so um and also i i you
know this advice is pretty consistent
that i give out
do trending stuff like however you can
work
trending into your business model if
that's like a comedian's going viral for
this
and you can get them an interview a
platform and everybody's talking about
that then people be like oh man i saw
xyz on on joe power
buyers podcast and he also has all these
other people on his podcast let me check
that out
so i think those are those are a couple
of things that
really there's no secret sauce man it's
just freaking relentless
hard work consistency and uh
posting stuff that you don't always
believe in and i know that's not like
that seems weird like what
you know people a lot of times content
creators they they feel like it's got to
be perfect
to post it and that's just not true you
just
you know it doesn't have to be perfect
to be posted so put it up someone will
like it most of
the time so yeah so almost like more
content is what you're saying i've heard
dame dash say that content is currency
now
is it just more and more like that's the
game right now i don't necessarily mean
more i think can you know
because more is relative for me a video
a day
is about all i can do and especially as
i try to launch this app or start to
launch this app well it's actually
technically launched but
we're in the like beta pre-phase i don't
have as much time to
make the daily videos as i always did
right because like i told you
before we started i was editing
something that's going up
on air you know and i i'm shooting four
or five sketches for this and i'm doing
podcasts and i'm doing
all these other things so i don't
necessarily want to just throw up a
thing that's bad
but my video a day might switch from a
side-by-side thing that i've researched
on the internet
so here's my promo for keep your
distance or music video you know what
i'm saying so
i try to operate very efficiently
um in in my approach so that i know like
as we keep going
as i keep going people and and now you
know year from now it might be
trailers for an episode of something but
it's a very funny trailer you know what
i'm saying so
you know like kevin hart and the rock
they're kind of my benchmarks because
they
get booked as much for their talent as
they do for their marketing and the
audience that they bring to stuff
and that's a currency thing and and
that's kind of what i want to do like i
have to be the creative
engine to market my own stuff because
i'm not quibby
joe bars i don't got 2 billion you know
what i'm saying
but what i do have like you see all
these uh clapboards in your comments
that's the stage crew
like i just put this in my patreon i
didn't even put this
out to the world yeah because i know my
patreon they be
pulling up if they're able and they got
time they'll pull up and and watch and
support
and you know and we'll put our
clapboards in there and
and that's my that's my other secret
sauce
you know and that's a lot of that's you
know
nine ten years of content like some of
the people in my stage crew
are patreon they've gone all the way
back to when my youngest son was
two or three years old and couldn't even
speak clearly
now he has his own podcast there's some
fans who remember when he was like
literally no that's how he used to talk
and now they're watching him sit next to
me and be like so what do you think
about the mandalorian
i like this and i like that and that's
my you know that's what i have
where what i really decided to focus on
was just
you know in the same sense of tyler
perry what i really admire about him
he doesn't care if critics love him
or if the public at large loves him he
wants
to make sure his audience loves him and
then if you
grow in his audience you like him you
know and that's where i've been like
yeah man you don't need
everybody the grateful dead doesn't have
everybody in their fan base
but they've got a freaking lot of
deadheads and the deadheads are
serious about the grateful dead and
that's kind of what i want
to to build and that's kind of what i've
been working on
yeah that is one thing i would say the
hot breath the verse that's what we call
ours our group the hot breath of verse
it's the hot brethren and sister in
in here and um someone said i'm like a
porcelain doll
so the crew is in the building okay
yeah y'all he is
reading these comments why would y'all
tell that man he's the person
who's into on his show i've been dude i
came up in atlanta like i've been
roasted way
worse than porcelain doll all right we
won't even
we won't even go to the street over here
came in the man's
house and didn't take our shoes though
like hey man this house is small
hey god you know we're at company's
house
no i think that was a statement person
joe that was somebody else
yeah they're saying it looks like we're
in the same house as well
that's funny
but i um when it when it comes to the
like
yeah i just i know you have like an
online course on your website about
social media and all that
and this show is centered around like
helping that next generation of great
comics like
what uh what kind of social media advice
do you have for like the next generation
out there how like it seems like that's
the tool but it seems like
i mean that i mean basically help us
kev on stage how can we use social media
as a tool and not a toy
uh here's the thing i'll say right
you may not be able to prove to people
that you are a funny stand-up comedian
on social media
right but you should be able to show
people that you're funny
and that's kind of like a lot of my fans
for a long time
didn't even know i did stand up they
only knew me for my videos
unless they had seen me at their you
know at their church or at
a club or something like that but they
had thought i was
funny for my video so you know there's a
lot of kind of og's of comedy who
for a long time balked at the idea of
being on social media
and then got mad that social media
comedians were getting booked it's like
you know the biggest mistake you can
make is to think a comedy club cares if
you're funny
they don't they care if you sell tickets
now back in the day you were funny you
got on big stuff you sold tickets
because
you were seen on comic view or comedy
central or whatever
and they had the representations
representation representation no
resident resume what is the word when
like
i'm known for doing something good
reputation
reputation they had the rep thank you
that was like a knee jerk dab you don't
even know what happened you're just like
ah i don't
i don't know what happened i just i dab
i don't know
they had the reputation like the comedy
store
if they're booked here you know they're
funny right but now
uh and at that time agents and managers
they were sitting in the audience
because that's how you book people same
thing was happening in music
now i have the ability to you know stage
crew
you know we've got a huge audience all
over the place i've got big audience in
atlanta if i post on instagram hey i'm
going to be in atlanta
they don't care about the club's
representation
reputation right they care about mine
so they're coming to see me because
they've seen me
laugh on you know social media so that
could be on twitter
you type funny tweets you do you know
funny memes they you know
think you're funny on podcasts sketches
desi banks he does a great job being
funny and sketchy he's one of my
favorite yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's and now he's doing
stand-up as well
he's he's hilarious on social media
country wayne
same thing they do a lot of sketch
comedy uh you know tony baker
he he does a lot of content but he's
known for uh animal voiceovers like that
has nothing to do with stand-up comedy
animal voiceovers but he's really funny
at it so people follow him and then he
can say hey i'm going to be in columbus
georgia
or hey i'm doing my own uh tony baker
friends on december 18th
come check me out right so you've got to
find out what medium and what
type of content best shows that you're
funny and then people follow you
and then you've got to create a
community right because not everybody
necessarily follows you and then once it
comes to your show
you got to take them from a fan to fam
and then you can monetize a lot of time
people just want you know
to make money off of people and it's
like okay like
that's like um uh a door-to-door vacuum
salesman like hey you wanna buy this
vacuum
oh no okay bye like that's how comics
approach social media like let me post
my flyers well
you're posting a flyer but i have no
reason to go why would i want to go
check you out
what do i want to do what makes you why
like let's
prove to me that you're funny first so
in my case my audience
it's been eight nine years of of making
funny content
most of which i never asked them for
anything i wasn't even selling merch
like i
just was like i don't want to ask i'm
afraid and then it was like also i do
stand up come check me out here
also i'm going on tour now i'm doing an
app or i'm selling merch
you know and that's kind of the whole
thing just you got to
you know prove that you're funny as much
as you can in the best way you can
so you prove you're funny and that is
like a difference between a following
verse followers is that community aspect
like how
can we as comics cultivate that
community and really start to nurture
that relationship beyond just
asking for things yeah i think part of
it is your content creation the other
part of is like
you know i used to as simple as
responding in the comments like you'd be
surprised
comics don't even respond ever
like how i respond to usually two or
three comics
on each platform and i don't i can't do
it as much as i used to but
i spawned two or three on facebook two
or three on instagram two or three on
youtube two or three on twitter
and that just lets people know that i'm
not just a piece of them i'm not a cog
in a machine i'm a real person
reading that now the drawback of that is
you read a lot of comments and they're
not all
positive but i i talk to my audience i
go live we talk directly to them
and it's not always here by this here by
that hereby this here by that like
re-establish uh you know kind of like a
relationship
and that's it's as simple as commenting
back to them hey what do you guys think
of this shirt and then listening
like um my audience is
great right i i test you know now for me
it's a lot easier because i have patreon
and that's like the core fan base these
people are the ones i know are gonna buy
something if it's
viable you know i'll throw hey what do
you guys think of this shirt they'll be
like yeah kev
drop it and sometimes they'll be like
this is the worst
ever don't sell this i believe i can't
say that yeah
dreams never die shirt i should have
asked them because
dreams never sell so you know
uh but that's been built up over over
time
okay cool yeah i believe they they'll be
honest they're being honest for sure
yeah oh porcelain doll i see
yeah yeah yeah because even that on that
merch game like you
you would you know fly across the
country for a hundred bucks but then
sell
fifteen hundred dollars in merch you
know the merch game's no joke
yeah man that's how i got by i remember
you know that story you're talking about
was in augusta i got 150 bucks
to get paid and i remember when i was
flying i was like this really doesn't
make any sense
but i had you know fifteen hundred
dollars worth of merch in my duffel bag
and i sold out so you know back then
most of my shows were free the church
would bring me
and cover my flying hotel and then the
show would be free they'd take an
offering or whatever
um and you know my currency was was
merchandise so
um i wouldn't say that i'm a great merch
salesman
uh but i try to give my people who
support me something about i'm actually
working on a new
uh thing to launch at the top of the
year that kind of coincides
that with the app but at the time that
was my
currency was like merch because you know
people were like well [ __ ] i had a great
time and i didn't pay for a ticket i got
30 bucks let me you know let me buy so
they might not even wear it you know i
used to sell dvds at this time
uh and when people had a great time
they'd be like let me buy everything you
got i buy three of these dvds
you know and one shirt you know so
that's like 60 70
bucks and that's better or more than
you know a ticket price yeah i'm i'm
seeing um
and i'm thinking you're saying the app
and you have the sound stage and you
have the studio and you have all these
podcasts and like
let me um i don't want to jump into a
fan questions here as well
but um i want to selfishly ask this one
and pick your brain a little bit more
because i really do feel like
we're on to something special here at
hot breath and in your
your instincts on your own experience
like
we have you know we have the weekly
podcast we do these q and a's we have
the facebook group we have the
membership group
we have this youtube channel like what
you
seem you started off with one and then
you built out but where do you see like
how can how can we keep pushing the
envelope forward we kind of have this
baseline
and you're saying be consistent but is
your instinct saying
even just try this or that and just
start to kind of mix it up a little bit
yeah i mean i who i try so many things
i mean literally so many things
um sometimes that's also realizing that
you're not good at one
you know like yeah vine idols like i
tried
some of the worst vines ever are on my
page i'm almost
glad that platform died just so you
can't go and search
how bad my vines used to be tick-tock
i didn't perfect it but i found that my
dad jokes worked on there so
i think it's about like i'll throw it
against the wall and even clubhouse
which is kind of an emerging
merging app i i i dip my toes in the
water there
because you just never know who you're
going to connect with on what platform
but i also know part of that is
realizing it's hard to
be uh i'll use the term dominant
on all platforms right with with you
know specific content for each so
i you know kind of focus the most
patreon is my most important app
by far because that's my direct line to
my audience
uh but that required me to build a good
youtube page youtube facebook
instagram now thank the lord you can
basically post the same video on those
but you need to take the extra time and
actually post
it there's a lot of people still posting
the link from their instagram
on twitter nobody's watching that and no
one's clicking that link you have to
post that video on twitter and cut it
down in two minutes and 20 seconds or
whatever
you know so that's part of it just first
making the content
uh and posting it natively um but
the way i kind of see it social media is
my job it's my
responsibility to be uh aware of all the
apps what's popping what's
dropping whatever and know what my
strengths are like periscope was a great
app for me because i'm long-winded i
could talk and talk and talk
so me and my audience when i used to be
driving to work for an hour and a half i
used to talk to them
four or five times a week for 45 minutes
for like a year
two years almost three years you know
and i only really stopped that when i
started patreon because
when i started patreon and i quit that
job because i didn't have an hour and a
half
in my day where i was like i couldn't do
anything but so many of my fans were
like
bro we used to be up in there having a
it was only like a
and this is what i need people to
understand
my periscope i never was big on
periscope
but we used to have the 95 is what our
my fan base was called
when we were on periscope 100 200 people
in there
we would be having the we would have the
time of our lives
in there so it wasn't about being viral
or crazy it was just about connecting
with my audience
every day we never had a crazy amount of
people in there and it wasn't about that
it was about
you know having a good time with my with
my fans and family
and them 200 people they came to patreon
their stage crew they're they're people
who are buying the tickets to keep your
distance
but that's years of free content where i
wasn't asking for anything we was just
hanging out having a good time and i
still really struggled to ask for
anything even to buy stuff but i
realized if i want to continue to do
this i gotta promote
you know my my uh
my business ventures so that's why i
promote but if i could find a way to
monetize
without promoting i would do it wow
yeah me too and prime even might lose
like if you watch sorry joe i don't mean
to cut you off no you're
we just got a super chat so thanks for i
know that then gave you two dollars joe
we out here we made it you did now
dabbed and raised the roof in the same
interview
we have got to get you we got to do the
whoa you got to you got to bring
one dance that's been released in the
last three years
at least a whoa joe i mean this right
here
your dog on raise the roof threw off my
train of thought i don't even know what
i was going to say
my bad man yeah but what i think we're
getting is the context for the amount of
work
i'm putting out just being authentic in
to the community
yeah man like my promo for keep your
distance is actually content whether or
not you buy a ticket
obviously it's my hope that you do yeah
if you don't buy a ticket you're still
like well dang that was a great sketch
so at least if you watch the full thing
i haven't got you to buy a ticket
but i might have got you to watch the
thing on youtube so i might have got an
ad dollar
out of you and that's the thing that i
had to realize some people are gonna
watch my stuff and
never buy a thing thankfully
the uh the youtube instagram facebook
i'm getting monetized so i can get that
money that way or maybe they never go to
keep your business but they're like i
like his content so i'm gonna get in on
the app
uh so i try to do all that stuff so i
get the
a chance to monetize in every way shape
or form but just know that it's not
it's not going to be everybody that's
just not how it works awesome
well let's uh let's get into some
questions here as well because i do want
to make sure
that um the crew and the hot breath of
verse get some questions answered
okay uh yeah this is this is gold yeah
thanks for all these gems
people are wondering if i can floss
they want me to do the floss now is it
i'm already setting us back i'm already
setting us back i can't keep going
oh let's get um erica switzer in here
she's a
an og member of the hot breath of verse
she like
just we do a live writing club on
youtube
in our facebook group where we get a new
word and write a new joke in 10 minutes
so she's been super active in there
okay um so she says uh kev i followed
you from the jump
and love seeing the growth will you
continue to produce more classics like
great taste
and saul incomplete but
no nehous ah it's hilarious
so great taste is a show from all that
from when i used to work there
um i won't i can't produce that specific
show because that's a property of all
death
but what i will be able to do is uh
create content that gives you that
chemistry camaraderie
vibe that great taste had what people
really liked about that whether they
knew it or not and a lot of people them
did
it was the chemistry it was these people
are having a good time together
it's not really important what they're
talking about i just want to hear them
talk
so we we're developing a couple shows
like that there and i'm definitely
now that i think i see that people are
really feeling the music videos
i'm definitely going to get a nehu um
either sketch or
full music video in there because so
many people love 90s r
b and they who's a big part like
angelica mister
uh she's in this chat she's a fan that's
at least
seven eight years old like at least
she's been
on my fan base forever guyanese gal
she's been coming on youtube for years
joel so this is kind of like what my one
of my patreon friends
was from when i lived in washington she
actually used to see me live when i
dressed up as
an old man and did this thing called
clayton earl
she's still on my patreon like seeing
these people in here
like that's how you build a family these
people are like i'm with you for a long
time so
i'm sorry i veered off on your question
but
it just it reminded me how long so many
people have been in here
no no that's beautiful i love that and
even um
like i really started focusing on
community really specifically since the
pandemic and really
cultivating an online community and it's
it's very rewarding just to see
you know mine is more it's comedy fans
but also like aspiring comics and just
seeing them
starting their writing journey and now
three six months later like
seeing the evolution and growth within
their own
comedy skill set it's just it's very
inspiring
that's dope man i love and that's what
like you know kind of booker t
washington said that cast down your
bucket to where you are there's
there's it's better for you to have 300
people or 30 people in the hot breath of
reverse
who really rock with you than a million
fans and none
really care like there's a lot of
influencers who have a lot of followers
yeah but no no community so when it
comes time to promote something
people are like no no just post that
video i like i don't actually want to do
anything and they have a hard time doing
this for a living because they have no
core fan base boom yeah
cast down your buckets where you are
people like that one
yeah man i mean kev got bars in here
and you're you're um your keep your
distance
ooh this is a good one this is from kmac
um
kev who is your dream comedian to book
for keep your distance
besides joel byers of course where are
you based at joel
i'm in the a okay
i'm gonna get you joe season two next
year
i just want to see you on stage i'm
gonna get you some time
on my word i'm gonna book you um amen
uh there's a couple of comedians but the
dream
arness jay i
love rnsj he's one of my favorite
comedians
he he just he just does him
in so many ways and he goes so
hard on physical comedy which i i do as
well so honest j i'd love kevin hart
just because i've been a fan of him for
so long
uh dave chappelle i'd love for him to
smoke and
drop knowledge you know ellen i
ellen's special when i was in college
where she did shoot at the very end
one of my favorite special jamie foxx
has my favorite joke of all time
my favorite joke i might just post it
today just to honor him
his brady bunch joke at the end of his
uh i might need security in oakland
no one can do that joke you can't even
steal that joke from jamie foxx because
it's
so personal to his life and he can play
the piano and sing
love it and uh monique i feel like
monique is a monster on stage
and uh i feel like you know because of
the netflix thing a lot of people were
like i'm only ain't even that funny on
stage okay first of all that's just not
true
how you feel about her is how you feel
but ain't nobody gonna say monique
wasn't
funny monique like bro i need y'all to
i need y'all to y'all need to recognize
gay monique was an
absolute monster on that stage so i
would love uh
to see her so those are kind of my
my favorite and jonathan slocum yo he
when i was a kid he was the first
church comedian that i thought was so
funny my mom had his
tapes and cds we used to listen to him
over and over
over and out like that might be actually
as i think about my life
he might have been more of an
inspiration than i even speak about out
loud
because he was doing jokes that about
stuff that i was seeing
and i didn't know that you could be
funny about this and he
did that in such a good way that i
thought that was possible
so i think those are those are my people
those are my eight yeah that was that
was me with sinbad when i saw afros and
bell bottoms
seeing him like talk about the sidewalk
squeaking and like i mean he was his
alliteration his characters and his act
outs i was just like
i want to do that yeah man sinbad
you know uh prayer is up for him as he
recovers for sure from a stroke
he is a monster that i don't feel like
it's talked about enough like he's also
a comedian that you know in a lot of
ways this is what i strive to be
he's clean but you don't think oh
sinbad's funny because he's clean he's
just funny you don't realize
wait did he cuss her i don't know if he
cussed or not like that's kind of how
i'd like my comedy to be
i don't want you to be like oh he was
funny for a guy who doesn't cuss like
he's just funny
yes yeah and um
yeah if you guys have questions put
question in front of them
um a lot of comments yeah there's a lot
of comments but if you have a question
yeah put uh just put questions in front
of it so i can find it because i had
someone
i remember um doogie54 asking
and i guess this is from this is from
your comedy hype interview recently
how did you keep a straight face when
doug williams kept calling you kevon
so doug williams calling me kevon he
gonna be on keep your distance this
friday
i kept a straight face because i had
already offended doug williams by
posting that
jamie foxx thing oh savage
yeah the last thing i wanted to do was
start a new thing with doug live but i
couldn't
i was like okay i gotta say something
you know i feel like marlo and the wire
like my name is my name
it was a little bit of a dicey situation
uh
to be in so i let it i let it go for a
lot longer than
than i normally would yeah because of
any waiting circumstances
but it is funny he's like man i love
what you're doing you're
really paving a path for comics all this
self-made ownership
keevon you're killing it most of that
interview you just let it slide
and then you're like hey i'll book you
and i'll fly you out you like kept like
putting like i i it was just a joke when
i posted your roast don't worry
hey i had to learn a lesson there joel
at that time posting that joke i wasn't
keyvan the comedian i was just kevin
fredericks the fan of
comedy and rose comedy and i wasn't
really realizing
how uh that my name carried weight in
the comedy industry because i don't
really think of myself like that
uh but i learned a lesson that day that
became much bigger and i really didn't
even mean it like that i was just like
man this is funny
so but i won't i won't be doing that as
naive
as i did did it that time
and i've had a few people asking will
you release the
keep your distance shows so
interestingly enough
i i will i am it's going to be on the
app
but it's not going to be um episode 1
is now available right i i wanted to
create something like comic view where
you get to see
seven or eight comedians doing three or
four minutes as opposed to like you get
to see this person's whole
set this person's whole set because i
felt like it's only right
one the live experience is the live
experience i want people who
watch that live show to feel like oh i
don't want to just wait and now i can
see that exact thing
on there and also uh sometimes people
performing for 20 minutes
like an hour and a half show isn't isn't
going to be as enjoyable
non-live as you think so the app
version will have a show that ranges
between 20 and 30 minutes that'll be the
best
you know boom boom boom of these jokes
it'll still feel alive in the sense of
i'm not going to cut the jokes down to
where it doesn't feel like a real set
you know but it won't be 22 minutes it'd
be
the best three minutes the best five
minutes here some people might have
you know because your joke might build
you might get seven minutes
but that's what's gonna happen and i
actually just sent
the notes for the first episode back
right now
uh literally that's what i was working
on before we did this and as soon as um
that gets finalized i'm gonna i'm gonna
go ahead and post it yeah those shows
are getting like tens of thousands of
people man
i mean i've been doing zoom shows with
tens of people
like honestly joe i'ma tell you bro a
lot of that
is my stage crew audience like they you
know my stage crew watches it live
they have a we in our discord we have a
private discord with our patreon
there's a group in there that they chat
about the show while it's happening with
their friends
so a lot of that i'd say 78 of that is
repeat customers
who either get the email reminder
there's a discount
for your email if you're on the email
list and there's a discount if you're in
the
if you're in the patreon discount on
your patreon is the same every time
uh the code switches for people in the
email so what i wanted to build was like
kind of like a comedy club in the sense
of like
i'm gonna go to every show i'm gonna
have a good time every time regardless
of who's on the stage
you know so hopefully with each new
comic they you know
i get new people because each each time
comics post their fans come and watch as
well
and it's my hope that i could you know
like when you come you're people from
the a
they dab they say
and then they they become a fan of the
show because they see you know four or
five other communities that they like
and then and they come back so that's
kind of what we're trying to build
uh and then i want to sell that show and
license it and you know say hey netflix
amazon
you know hulu here's here's new
comedians because i've been watching
yes and for the last 10 or 15 years
every time there's a new stand-up comic
comedy show
80 of the people on there are comedians
who already had their
tv credits like you get one or two new
faces like
our show we flipped that we said we're
gonna have one or two people you've seen
on tv before
ninety percent of the people that you
see are our comments who don't have
those big tv credits like that and
that's where you're going to come and
deserve
uh discover new comedians and that's the
goal and if i don't sell it that's fine
it'll be content on my app
and that's what i hope to build yeah
that's what we're that's what we're
doing here is really
trying to showcase the next generation
of great comics the like the the ones
you don't know
yet type yeah cause you are like i love
cedric the entertainer and i'd love to
have him on keeper distance
but if you don't know who says the
entertainer is by now you've been living
under a rock
he's been famous since i was in high
school like
his set by the way on uh well everybody
on
uh kings of comedy was amazing yeah but
like
i've you've known about said from there
he was on the steve harvey show steve
harvey he's done
family feud like who is t murph
you know have you heard of t murph yet
he murph's hilarious out of chicago
um people found out about him from keep
your distance then they went and watched
him unwoke
now he you know he's on woke on hulu and
that's what i want people to do like
that's how i found said from that movie
and then watched him throughout his
career i want you to find team murph
and kenisha buss and you know cp
and angel tanksley like oh i found them
on this and now they're on that
but you've already known about them and
now they can say hey here's my
audience that i bring to the table so
that's kind of how
that's kind of the whole you know idea
that you know for keeping distance i
built this platform but it's not just
for me
it's for comedy you know and that's just
the comedy show
with the app i hope to do that for
unscripted content and short films and
and feature link films and you know
podcasts and all that type of stuff
that's kind of
you know what i want to do with my
platform uh and this wasn't always the
plan i
i don't think but it's become the plan
the last five years it's for more than
me and i really struggled as a christian
like what are people gonna
think if you know they see people
cussing and i'm like
it's more than just for me it
it feels selfish to have this whole
platform
and just personally get rich and big
it feels more of a great use of this
platform
to help others and also get rich i don't
want
you to think i don't want to just not
first
i don't want to be the only one rich
yeah yeah i want
all my friends in the gated community
i'm here i'm up in the gated community
now i want to get angel in the gated
community and tony it's here in the
gated community
team murph in the gated community like
you know back in the day like kenisha
i'm a quick aside and i hope i'm not
hijacking the interview you're doing
great buddy
kenisha bus had bar none
not only my favorite set from keep your
distance one of my favorite sets
from stand-up comedy in my life wow like
keep your distance and she didn't
license it to us and this and i'm
i'm happy this set is like back in the
day you remember when like
uh tim allen he got the show based off
his bit
yeah and roseanne they got shows based
off their bits
her set was like that right it was like
oh you
you deserve a tv show this is this is i
could see
like if i were a network except i would
develop a tv show so
my hope is that she can take that set
and tour with it like develop it tour
with it
and get a show off it and even if i
didn't do nothing else
but you know remind you how funny she
was
that's great like i i'm okay with that
like when she said no and i asked her
she was like cam come on now and i was
like
i had to ask you know but uh
i want my platform to be that for
everyone
who you know as much as i can obviously
i can't be everything to everybody i
can't take every show i can't
approve everything but if if she gets a
show
and it's just even in part because of
her saying that keep your distance
i i'm i'm i'm in heaven that's great to
me it doesn't have to be
on my app you know i don't have to own
everything or license everything
for me to be happy for people who get
their you know get a break
as a result of you know my health yeah
people are asking about
like your sound stage and like how
that'll work and this is i guess
specifically nana p
asking how the sound stage will work are
you
branching out to a circle of friends or
only open it for creators in la
like what yeah are you opposed to
opening up to other people what's your
plan with it
uh that's a great question uh and i'll
answer it like this
it'll be in phases so the reason we got
it is because i'm sure you know
booking locations is expensive and the
bigger the space is you pay you know
sometimes five thousand dollars a day
right that's an insane cost so with our
sound stage
you know we were looking at we were just
outgrowing like my personal office is
was basically just for podcasts there's
not much room to shoot anything else in
there
and my business partner brennan his
space was getting too small for the
stuff that we were doing
so you know we went out looking for a
space so that when we shoot a movie
or a unscripted series we can have a
full green screen because you know we
have to go
rent a full green screen green screen
white site
that's 1500 a day now we have that
in here now we can help shoot podcasts
and all that type of stuff
but to answer your question initially
it's just going to be for our stuff
because
you know we got to you know use it there
first
but eventually i don't know if it'll
ever be like youtube space la
where you just come in and shoot there
because that requires
insurance at supreme levels requires
like crew and people to mend that
but at least shooting things for the app
you know that we believe in it'll be
used for that um
in the future when i get into
philanthropic philanthropic areas
i'd love to get a space that is like
youtube space
where you can just come in and shoot and
the cameras and stuff are there uh
that's definitely something that i want
to do i don't know if it'll be this
specific place where we're actually
shooting and using it there if that
makes sense
yeah how i saw this question as like the
comments keep popping up but like
someone was asking about like
what is your 10-year plan and like is
your is your career
fairly like planned out like are you do
you have it kind of in stages
i couldn't first of all joel i couldn't
even have
thought from this year the beginning of
this year to where we are
this year never would have thought that
like mind you so
i don't know if you know this we we got
kicked out of our first office
because of racism we call that the
racism office um
we got kicked out in february this year
we got our
our current podcast studio in february
march happens a doggone global pandemic
shuts all that down i'm on tour i got 70
dates
me into here did i don't know eight
cities
so i'm sitting there march 15th you know
22nd hearing from my agent like yeah
all your april's canceled and all your
maze cancelled and june's not looking
good either
so to go from that to creating keep your
distance
and and uh the idea to get an app
also happened during this time and then
being able to have the resources to go
out and get
i can't even couldn't fathom this
these 12 months so i wouldn't dare
disrespect god
to think about where 10 years could be i
could be
a household name on forbes magazine
right
but my goal all my goal it's only broken
down to i want to make great content
for people to see and get opportunities
for others
if that's my app if that's netflix
saying we love you so much we're gonna
give you a hundred million dollars
and i'm gonna be like nah man a hundred
jillion
that's what i'm talking about like i
don't even know what that could be so
i won't disrespect god by trying to see
how that looks practically all i'll say
is i hope that
in 10 years i am still holding true to
making content that i want to see
making content that my audience wants to
see and giving other creators a chance
and giving them opportunities that's
really all i want to do
for the rest of my life i love that i
love how clear that vision is though the
intent behind what you're doing
yeah yeah that part is clear as today
and honestly in some ways i've been
doing that since i was back in
washington we were doing plays
and not making a dime we were still
giving people an opportunity to act in
tacoma
who there was no there was not many
opportunities to act in a play in tacoma
so i'm really just doing the same thing
i've been doing like even the sketches
you see we've
you've seen look at my old youtube we've
been doing music videos we just did a we
did a capri sun
song 10 years ago i just didn't have the
resources i have now to actually make it
look good
i've been doing music forever i just did
it on instagram with the music playing
out of my computer
now because of my business partners and
you know where i'm in life i can really
just make it look nice but in some ways
i'm i'm doing what i've always been
doing
you know what i'm saying i love it so uh
can we can we do a couple more questions
here
no baby wait one more
let's do another 15 minutes jolly we
having a good time
we got 15 hot breath verse i love it i
love it
that's what i do love about some comics
have been like yeah let's do 30 and then
they get in here and they're like yeah
let's keep going this is awesome
keep going joe we're having a great time
i appreciate you kev
ah he's doing it
[Laughter]
we're bringing it back dude i i tell my
wife all the time i'm bringing the dab
back i'm gonna bring it full circle
i'm with you i've been actually saying
we need to bring back
i raised the roof with a simple dance
that i could do with confidence we need
those back the dougie
i got off the train at the duggar i was
like okay i don't this is too many
things
yeah the stinky leg i didn't have the
coordination oh yeah
my knees are bad yeah i know i can i'm
too tall for that yeah
i'm not a ball player i'm just a tall
player
it's for all my gucci fans out there
i cannot get a read on you joe you look
like you went to a private school in
marietta
and then you quote gucci and i'm like
okay so who are you
i have a whole bit in my special about
the trailer to the trap like uh
like homies and honkies and all this
like it's
it's i got it you're confusing me i'm
like all right
what now you gonna go to like that oh
yeah east atlanta santa all day yeah
yeah
uh i know it's i'm just as confused as
you are trust me it's
i'm glad i have comedy though that's for
sure
[Music]
so um this comes from actually when we
talk about
day one fans um comedian yoshi here
this podcast started five and a half
years ago he he's been
on it since day one so it's good to see
him in the chat
um he asks what do you think comics
should stop doing versus what comics
should be doing more of
um i think comics should stop
taking themselves so seriously and uh
and and do more stuff there and unsure
of
if it will work or not a lot of times
comics get into the like
you know ah it's gotta have the perfect
this perfect that perfect this
it doesn't it can be okay i've laughed
at a lot of okay videos like
and that might be enough for me to want
to see more from you so that's the main
thing and
you stop taking yourself so seriously
and stop complaining
so much about what works for other
comics like i
that's one of the things in the comedy
community is just be like well this
person only got big because of that and
he only does this
and then bro but what does it matter
like a lot of times comics our biggest
mistake
we care too much what other comics think
and not enough what audience members
think
comics don't buy tickets they don't have
they even in comedy clubs they usually
get to walk in for free it's an unspoken
ruling comedy if you're a
comedian you get to come in for free
they're not the ones that are coming to
buy your show in charlotte
so care about what the audience members
who actually want to come see you live
care about and that will be better than
impressing a
whole bunch of comics with which a lot
of times they're that's not even
consistent
across comedians so i'm focused on my
audience thinking i'm funny
not random comedian x y or z boom
anything else we should be doing more of
um posting
you can the internet is the new
club it's the new billboard it's the new
tv show so why are you not marketing
yourself
it's called social media social meaning
let's connect with our friends and
family
media meaning let's promote ourselves so
i think that's the part a lot of us
forget about it is media it is marketing
every day you're marketing yourself you
know i'm i'm currently beefing with
jonathan mcreynolds
one of my friends from the gospel
industry and i'm gonna let your audience
and my audience in on a little secret
prior to this beef you know me and john
are just playing we had talked about
going on tour together right
so now i'm like oh we got this little
like fake beef going
but if we decide to go on tour in 2022
they're gonna be like oh i remember that
fake beef they had in 2020. i'd go
see that right so everything i do is
with
intention and strategy i i rarely just
do anything
more than once just just for the fun of
it
yeah and that was actually a comedian
indie actually just asked
are are there any future collaborations
with jonathan mcreynolds
so good timing actually we are we shot
an episode with him before our beef
began
on the app so that's one of the first
four episodes of the
real comedians challenge show um that's
going to air
so of course i don't do anything for
play play joe
everything everything has a reason
behind it
[Music]
i'm i'm working on getting better at
that i'm using like
improv mind of just running gun but
strategy
there's value to that as well a lot of
strategy joe
a lot of strategy oh i love it oh and a
lot of people saying
you do need to book me and i get a plate
at the barbecue people are saying so
okay see now black people we always want
to give the plate away quick
we just met joe let's let's check his
references first
let's see i know we gotta we gotta we
invite people to the cookout then we get
maddie like oh this is it
y'all ain't gonna know your middle name
we already invited the cookout
we already let's see let's check them
out first
that's that's how hey that's what
happens man they get me and they're
colonizing the barbecue
you know you gotta and that's what i'm
talking about you you don't dig it down
and make people laugh they're like man
bring him to the cookout hold on
man can he trust let's see
her check his tweets
i put a question in the in the chat joe
uh that i thought was good
uh and i'd love to answer if you if you
don't oh please yeah yeah i didn't know
you could see it also
yeah the questions uh yeah yeah the
question says how has the
increase in popularity and media
attention affected the dynamics in your
marriage relationship
with your sons that's right this is
probably been the hardest part of this
year joel
is recognizing that regardless of how i
see myself
there is a way that people see me on the
internet and
it would behoove me to be aware of how
big my platform
is and what the impact is and and react
accordingly so
in my marriage in some ways from my wife
she loki was like i don't know if i want
to do this
because this is a lot this is like you
got to understand joe my wife didn't
sign up for any of this she just wanted
to work
at boeing or something like that working
nine to five have a little house and
come back i'm the one who wanted to do
all this so
what it required of me is to be more
private than i naturally am i am not
really a private person
but this year i saw how social media
and things that i was really open about
got used against me
so now i'm like okay let me let me
be more careful about what i share
because uh
not not that i need to like go into my
shell but there's a lot of and my dad
had been telling me this there's a lot
of benefit to
uh sharing only uh certain parts of your
life
not everything in your life and i had to
learn the hard way a lot this year
that i can't just say what i want i
can't just
share what i want because the size of my
platform i have to be more responsible
than
i had planned on with my sons you know
they kind of grew up on the internet and
they kind of decided to take a
a step back you know individually and
then my younger son uh wanted to start a
podcast so they're more
aware of what that looks like but for
them that's like you know honoring their
request my oldest son very rarely wants
to be on camera so he if you ever see
him i've asked his permission
most of the time he says no he's just
like that's not really my thing
my younger son we'd be going ham we have
a great time
shooting and making videos so but i've
got to be particular about what i do
like even one time joining a whole job i
was in hawaii
and i made a video of me yelling at the
beach right made a funny video
at the beginning of my uh time at the
beach
and a fan in hawaii saw that and came
to where we were to try to book me for
something
so i learned i can't do that anymore
because for my children's safety like
luckily she's a fan and she meant well
yeah but if she was deranged i just put
my family
in jeopardy you know so and when i was
on the road last time
somebody snuck up another fan snuck up
behind me like yo cam i want to do this
i'm like yo
like he came literally out of the dark
so i'm like okay next time i go on tour
i i don't want to go without security
because it's not that i you know think
i'm you know
uh all that but it is like that's a
couple of times in within
six months 12 months that if someone had
bad intentions
i would have been exposed so i you know
that's a part of my career that i would
you know never really thought i would
have to do but now i might have to do
yeah even and that there are so many
parallels between us
it's wild um but that's the same thing
with my wife is like you know she didn't
ask for any of this but she
she's happy to support me and believes
in me and things like that but it is
part even if i'm on the road
i'm i'm sometimes doubtful of posting
that i'm on the road
just because i don't want people to know
you know that she's like back home
like and i'm not there type deal
absolutely
absolutely uh well i mean i didn't know
you could see the chat are there any
other questions
that um
that uh you um and ty
jr asked one for me not to brag here
but he asked my big break
which um i mean i don't i wouldn't say
i've had a big break i've had
big moments um and experiences
but um probably the moment in my career
that
solidified my comedy journey was i
do you know griff are you familiar with
the comedian griff 2 trillion
yep yeah so i did a church with him
probably two or three years in
in front of 1500 people my biggest
audience and i
killed and from then on it just like
that was the moment where i was like oh
i can do this and this is what is
possible it's not all open mics in front
of four people
but this is the possibility with comedy
so that was probably the moment
this is your interview but i just wanted
ty you know we i was curious
but that was the moment i was curious
yeah so thanks for asking ty
uh i see comments asking how do i get on
keep your distance comedy
next year we're gonna open up more of a
submission process
um the problem with this
this is what i'm trying to solve for
because the show has a certain rep
rep oh god what is that word
i don't know why reputation just been
beating me up today
um i want to make sure that the comics
that are
on there are representative of the
level of the show that is so i might i'm
thinking of like how do i
create uh uh showtime at the apollo type
of
show where people who are more amateur
or i'm not sure about
i can see them and see how people
respond to them and then maybe promote
them to keep your distance
i'm just trying to figure out what that
looks like but you know season two
i want to continue to find new and new
people
but at the same time make sure that if
you're on that stage
you keep up they're like oh man this
this person deserves to be
here uh on that stage mm-hmm
exactly a lot of toms do you know what
he's working on
hey time is the thing we created on on
all deaf
my boy to hear he stumbles over his
words all the time
so when i say i used to do like when i
would he would mess up i'd say hey tom
tina mess up another word so now they're
using it against me this is what you got
to be careful about your fan base
they know so much they'll use your own
jokes against you
and it's it was perfect time i was
hoping they wouldn't do it but they they
did it
oh i've gotten roasted so many times by
my audience dude like
because we do the writing club every
morning at 10 a.m and some mornings
i'm just not with it or you know i
didn't
i didn't shower beforehand and i just
get roasted so
people love oh and big j in dallas said
comedian griff is hilarious
yeah oh yeah for sure he he was my
efficient
actually and i cried and he
booed me
really uh i'm keeping it a bean right
now
all the way on a hundred he booed me
at my own wedding i'm gonna look you up
drama look send me some of your sets
after this i want to see you on stage
oh i definitely will yeah yeah i've been
in the game about ten and a half years
now it's just like
that's why it took me eight years to
realize stop relying on other people
like i kept being like
why isn't this club booking me or like
whatever it's like why am i not on conan
it's like no what can you control you
can book your own tour do your own tours
produce your own special you know it's
just like yeah focus on what you can
control
which we can control 458 people watching
and if you all
subscribe we will almost get to 8 000
subs
so pull up and holler at you subscribe
right now joe hot breath reverse i'm
joining now
i'm starting right now joe oh i was
really doing it because i had
i did it live and i had i hadn't muted
the channel yet
i appreciate that yeah yeah and that
sounds like patreon is another good
social media platform people are
maybe sleeping on in terms of using it
as an actual way to engage with your
audience and not just throw
extra content on you know oh yeah man
that's the big thing people are
you know a lot of times people just put
like what can i sell what can i sell but
like
for me like especially going into the
app my patreon is just going to be like
a private social media
with my fans you know and that's like
you know we go behind this
like oh i just did the cisco music video
and one of the funniest bits in there
i put a do-rag on the tiger that came
from one of my patreon people
watching live and being like kev you
should put a dewrack on the tiger
and then my boy was like kev one of your
fans said this and i was like that's
hilarious like
that's just one example of you know
bringing the freight my fam
into the process because as i get bigger
it's gonna be harder and harder for me
to connect with people like that
so i'm gonna make sure if i can't do
anything
well anymore i will focus on patreon
because these people have decided to
take you know five dollars three out
three dollars ten dollars out of their
pocket
every month and support me i'm gonna
make sure that they get
more of me than anybody else by the way
joel i just want to pause
these are the last five comedians on
your page before me
roy wood jr jeff foxworthy angela
johnson
gary owen our last four yeah
dude what the heck what are you on right
now
that's an amazing group of comedians i'm
trying to tell the people that's why i'm
asking
you kev what do we got to do here
because we're doing it look at this
you literally have everybody on here run
funches lunell
lewis bell you got big people you got
new people
you got tommy davidson you got
everyone on here nate i don't know how
to pronounce that nate bargassie
yeah yeah he has a really good special
on netflix i liked him a lot yeah for
sure
uh you're killing it bro
that's what i was doing asking you like
what what do i got to do to like let the
like get the people to know but it may
just be consistency as well like you
said
consistency is is you you have the
content i can just tell
by uh who your guest is
and you've only been on your first video
is two years ago
when desi banks your first video desi
banks
right now watch this desi banks is
popular more popular
now than it was two years ago do you
have an instagram do you have a way to
cut that
and and post it on on youtube instagram
and tag
desi have you done all that uh i will i
i used to be super consistent
more i used to be more consistent and
i've i've honestly like all my focus has
been in our facebook group
for a little while now just just being
active there but i do need to like
to get more awareness it is more
consistent on social for sure
yeah you got to use each you gotta you
gotta you gotta
use all your powers together because
like desi banks is much bigger on
instagram than he is on youtube
so maybe you tag him in the story if he
he reposted somebody who's a huge desi
banks fan
wants to hear that interview and goes
and clicks it and then they see
oh snap like right now they see desi's
interview but also i see oh he got ali
siddique in here
he got tamara goins who's one of the
biggest agents in black comedy
he's got carlos miller i know these
people so now they're checking
them out as well and you're kind of
connecting those dots
from you know because youtube is kind of
a closed society
it's not really as shareably social as
it used to be
facebook and instagram are much more
shareably social than that so facebook
is a good one
uh to build to build that on so you're
on the right track
yeah when did you start outsourcing like
video editing and podcasting and things
like that
when did you start to like outsource
those types of so
i would still say 80 of the videos you
ever see from me are shot and edited by
me
right i i outsourced my podcast to josh
my boy joshi guns when i was on the road
and
i remember specifically the day i was i
was like man you know this before i
brought him on full time
i had a show that night and i was
chopping a video down and i was just
like
i gotta get ready for the show i don't
have the energy to do this
so i said you know if i gave
him if i paid him to edit these for me
i could probably create enough videos in
that time with that renewed
energy to cover his cost
right so a lot of times it's about
scaling like i watch a lot of shark tank
and what happens is businesses get to a
point where they can't grow any more
without more space resources or
employees so that's kind of where we are
now that's why
getting this new office was scary but
i have we had outgrown our space so i
could probably
generate enough income by creating more
content
in that space than trying to nickel and
dime or you know fit into a smaller
space so
it gets to the point where to make
to make your business more efficient and
do what you do well like
yes i can edit but is it the best use of
my time
even if it's just most of my podcast was
just chopping the end off
where i turned the camera on chopping
the end off where i turned it off
and uploading that but even that small
thing would take three hours
to chop export post on
facebook post on youtube cut a piece out
on instagram
paying josh i just give myself three
hours
four or five times a week that i can now
think of some
new joke new podcast do another show
that type of thing so it's like ray
charles i was reading his biography
he didn't buy a private plane to flex he
bought a private plane because he
realized
after 10 o'clock you can't really fly
anywhere um
can't get a commercial flight anywhere
but if i have a private plane
when i leave uh boston i can fly
and be in you know the next in in
chicago in in two and a half hours
i'll never forget the moment you know
it's my goal i have a private plane by
the way joe i'm just gonna share that
with you
love it i saw kevin hart in at the
staples center a couple years ago
had a great time me and my wife date
night i mean blast it was hilarious saw
a lady get kicked out for using her cell
phone they literally drunk her out and i
was like this is crazy
right and i'm way up in the nosebleed me
and my wife have a great time
go home go to bed i wake up the next
morning
kevin hart is on set in boston shooting
a movie
and i was like what
that only happens because he had the
money for a private jet now this isn't
my pitch to get a private jet but it
shows you how
it was an efficiency play he could get
that tour money
in la on friday night saturday morning
he gets paid to be in a movie he's
actually probably making more he said
this a couple of times
he made more on tour than he made from
his movies or
yeah made from his movies but his star
rose more
because of his movies so yes that
private flight is expensive
but he's going to make that back 10
times over
boom yeah jeff foxworthy said the same
thing he he had a private jet so he
could fly home to be able to take his
kids to school in the morning
i would absolutely do that there if i
could if it was that difference between
not seeing my family and seeing my
family
because of that i would invest in that
because it's important to me to
to be there and that's the one thing
about the pandemic that's been great
i've been at home more than i've been in
my life most of us
and but especially me the last two years
touring
it allowed me to reconnect with my kids
i learned their middle names i hadn't
said that in a while
you know what i'm saying like i'm able
to build a podcast with my son but
generally i wouldn't have
not only because i'm traveling because
he he's a competitive he's a really good
soccer player
and he has practice two or three times a
week in tournaments all weekend but now
we start a podcast
we're going to be doing that weekly and
that's you know the pandemic has changed
so many things
you know that being one of them oh man
well
i mean i i feel like without the
pandemic we wouldn't have connected
either you know
so it's like it's it's beautiful there's
no way
making no repository your distance
wouldn't have
there's no way i would have ever thought
about doing keep your distance without
the pandemic
there's just like the circumstances
created the content
i just capitalized off of it but if the
world is the same
i would be like bro i'm going on the
road because that's the most money i
thought i could ever make i would never
thought i could
i used to be on the road joel like man i
love stand up but if i could just be at
home
after this yeah that would be great uh
and now i found a way to do that it's
not the traditional way but
it's a it's a way that works
so let's land this plane you gotta you
have a busy day here
um jay phrygian's saying you should
get me on a case study on your master
class do you do case studies on there
uh i do case study it's pronounced
phrygian
region yo my bad i'm sorry i had to ask
her
uh region yeah i would definitely look
into
doing a joe buyer's case study on my
master class i need to update
that by the way oh okay then won't he do
it let him use you
okay just take it easy joe byers my bad
you're all over the black community now
you're in the church you're in the trap
i dude i came up in atlanta like just do
i was never on the cool shows you know
like i never got booked on like the hip
popular shows i was just going wherever
i could get stage time
and most of that was just in like the
hood rooms that's really how i came up
as a comic so it's just like
it's just in me black people gonna make
a way even for white people we're gonna
be like
then joe cool that's my boy like joe nah
man we went to high school together he's
straight
man i appreciate the crew for hanging
out and um bringing us together with the
hot breath
verse and uh you kev we always we always
in these episodes with two things the
first one is just
your favorite comedy advice um something
you picked up over your career what is
like your favorite comedy advice that
you could bestow to the next generation
of comics here
um if you tell your story
your life authentically no one can steal
that joke
and that's why i focus on doing things
from my point of view
i mean it's i mean technically somebody
cancel that joke but it's going to be
really hard to steal
my life story uh and
when you bomb get back up there i bombed
two weeks ago and i hadn't bombed that
hard in a
minute yo that was a sobering reminder
i it was great like i mean not in the
moment but afterwards it was like oh
yeah you can still bomb
you you definitely have the potential to
still bomb so uh but you'll live you
live to find another day if it happened
live
i'm going to get it back you feel me you
ever been booed before
what booed
booed out of black i had a step show
and i made the great mistake of
mispronouncing one of the
um i was introducing a fraternity and i
called them by a sorority's name
and i was promptly booed and for the
next three hours i was hated
and i didn't do another black step event
for like
eight years i had dog on ptsd
post-traumatic step show
well i i appreciate all the kind words
from the crew
and uh you kev the final thing guests do
could you look into the camera
say your name and why comics should
listen to hot breath
yo it's your boy cam on stage and you
should listen to hot breath because
joel has all the keys that you didn't
know you needed
foul my man ladies and gentlemen show
some love for kev on stage everyone
kevin frederick appreciate you guys man
thank you joe i'm gonna hit you up bro
dm me what's your instagram
absolutely the instagram is joel byers
comedy
j-o-e-l-b comedy
and uh hot breath follow me on the gram
joe what you talking about dude i am
so not active on there that's what we
were just talking about
like i'm i honestly have not been active
and consistent on any social media
except like the hot breath facebook
group lately so okay well follow me back
so i can book you bro and send me a sec
yeah oh already done deal all right my
brother i appreciate you thanks
thanks crew we'll see you all right
catch up with y'all see y'all tomorrow
you